Because the socialist party is not an alternative,
en 1 political formation
that intends to continue with the alternation in power
to promote its policies,
which are none other than pardoning coup plotters,
expel Spanish from the classroom,
defending criminals and promoting skills.
In short,
deceiving all conservatives.
1 alternation led by mr.
illa
to defend criminals and abandon
to honest angels.
Mr. illa,
you the pardons and ended up defending them.
He denied amnesty and ended up praising it.
He defended the Constitution and now promotes skipping it.
VA in a few months
to promote the referendum as well.
Termination fact,
you have betrayed millions of angels,
lady,
will pay for it.
You and Mr.
,
have no doubts.
While you and Mr.és
do not do everything in your power
to restore freedom,
the prosperity and equality of all Spaniards,
we conservatives are not going to stop defending ourselves.
And yes,
hyperventilated communist gentlemen,
we will defend the legacy of our
and the future of our children
in self-defense